when putin sent tanks into ukraine he
started a war that quickly became much
bigger than just an invasion
everywhere you look all sorts of
relationships are changing between
countries
between economies
and between people and their governments
our correspondents around the globe
report on how this attack is having
consequences for countries and people
far from the battlefield
but let's start in ukraine itself
this war is a fight for ukraine's
survival as an independent state one
which will answer the question of where
its future lies the majority of
ukrainians have solved this question a
long time ago they want to be aligned
with the west but the western partners
especially in europe had doubts about
this they were debating this question
much to the frustration of many
ukrainians further and further the
resolve that the ukrainians have shown
in this war has changed this and now
ukraine's ambitions to be part of the
west are recognized by many partner
countries the most notable sign of this
shift in western perception was the
beginning of the membership process by
the european union something that
ukraine has long asked for but that was
always rejected by europe on different
grounds
so in the end this war has not only
brought ukrainians closer together it
has not only united the country and has
also diluted doubts about each other
about the western ukrainians about the
eastern ukrainians and the eastern
ukrainians about the western ukrainians
it has also brought ukraine and the west
closer together
the flip side to this a massive divide
between the west and russia
internationally russia is now more
isolated than ever at least in the west
and this divide between russia and the
west is here to stay not just for weeks
or months but for many many years russia
has become a pariah state an outcast
this had led moscow on the increasingly
desperate search for new partners
elsewhere be it selling more oil to
china or servicing western built planes
with the help of iran iran is
interesting because it's a country that
has been internationally sanctions for
decades and learned to live with and
work around the sanctions and also the
baltic states are pushing back against
moscow latvia lithuania and estonia have
clamped down on immigration from russia
and are striving for energy independence
here in latvia where i am now there is
even talk of tearing down all soviet
monuments from the past the iron curtain
is back like it was in the soviet union
if that was one of putin's goals the
restoration of the soviet union he
successfully achieved that goal at least
as far as the cold war is concerned
the war has highlighted ukraine's vital
role in feeding the world tens of
millions of tons of grain have been
stuck in storage due to the fighting
people in many places are feeling the
pressure africa may be thousands of
miles away from the war in ukraine but
dining tables here are taking a hit
nigeria imports more than 80 percent of
its wheat and almost half of the food
served in nigerian homes are derived
from wheat things like bread noodles
pasta and cereal many nigerians who were
already dealing with inflation after the
kobe 19 lockdown are facing the threat
of hunger and even starvation the rising
cost of food and increasing poverty has
worsened the problem of insecurity all
across the country crimes like
kidnapping for ransom are on the rise
and things are projected to get worse if
nigerians continue to get more
dissatisfied with the government over
its failure to get a grip of the
economic and security situation the
president faces the threat of being
impeached before the general elections
in 2023 nigeria has the biggest
population in africa political
instability here could spread beyond its
borders to the rest of west africa the
diplomatic fallout has also been global
india has long been friends with russia
to get weapons the west won't sell and
as a buffer against major rival china
india is re-examining this because of
how the west sees such a friendship and
because things between russia and china
are shifting
despite india's proximity to russia
successive indian governments have been
warming to the united states they see
washington's a key partner at many
levels
this war in ukraine has exposed what
some see as india's strategic ambiguity
despite initial fumbling india seems to
have found its balance on the diplomatic
tie probe when it discovered the western
world was not keen to push india into a
diplomatic corner at this very sensitive
time india gained confidence the foreign
ministry began talking about balancing
india's interests and it reacted sharply
at what it perceived as western double
standards especially when it came to
importing russian oil but all this could
backfire because india's refusal to
condemn russia's invasion of ukraine
could weaken its mantra of territorial
integrity and sovereignty especially
when it comes to china the two countries
are rivals and neighbors they share a
long border they have territorial
disputes and they have a fraught
relationship
in this context if russia and china come
closer together it could make it very
difficult for india and it could once
again start wobbling on the diplomatic
tightrope
in the midst of the ukrainian war
india's initial shaky position
stabilized and even gained traction it
was envied by countries who could not
afford to choose one side over the other
and india is a part of many multilateral
groups some overlapping and some not
this increased its diplomatic space to
maneuver and also enhanced its sense of
importance
not far away china carries out
unprecedented military drills in the
taiwan strait putting taipei on edge
they were portrayed as a reaction to
america's top parliamentarian nancy
pelosi visiting the democratic island at
the beginning of august
taiwan held defense drills of its own
with an eye on parallels between itself
and ukraine
taiwan's ministry of national defense
said this year's exercise is based on
war game simulations that are modeled
after lessons learned from the russia
ukraine war it includes scenarios like
fighter jets intercepting invading
warplanes and also
helicopters playing cat and mouse with
submarines taiwanese president tain once
said these exercises reflect the ability
and determination that taiwan can defend
itself
and this is also the first time that the
ministry of national defense has called
on reservists to join the exercises
highlighting the importance of ensuring
taiwan's combat readiness as the war in
ukraine continues
one of the biggest changes that has
taken place here in taiwan over the last
few months has been taiwanese people's
growing awareness of the risks of a
potential military conflict with china
and their willingness to participate in
first aid and combat related training
to a place now where asia and europe
meet
turkey is playing a complex role in the
crisis one that could become harder to
manage in the months ahead the war has
put turkey in a difficult position as a
member of nato the country is
strategically aligned with the west but
president recep tayyip erdogan and his
government are performing a delicate
balancing act supporting ukraine while
trying not to antagonize russia turkey
has provided kiev with combat drones but
resisted joining western sanctions
against moscow and the turkish leader is
trying to turn the challenge into an
opportunity casting his country as the
most engaged mediator between the two
sides erdogan facilitated the first
attempts at peace talks and played a key
role in securing the grain deal signed
by russia and ukraine in july aimed at
averting a global food crisis and he is
using this center stage position to
project greater turkish influence in the
broader region but also internationally
vis-a-vis the west but as the war drags
on and with an election coming up here
in turkey in 2023
observers are asking how long erdogan
can continue his balancing act or
whether he will have to pick a side
the west led by the u.s is now having to
face in two directions at once
plans to make china the primary focus
for geopolitical attention have had to
be adapted
that's because russia has once again
emerged as the west's rival and folk
raising the specter of the cold war the
us sees russia as a dangerous agitator
with nefarious aims to upend western
democracy and reshape the global
security order there's been a shift in
rhetoric and tone
there was much made of washington's
pivot to asia during the obama
administration during the trump
administration china emerged as a key
adversary china certainly hasn't
disappeared from the picture but
attention has been jolted back to europe
the war has made one thing pretty clear
the u.s still provides the backbone of
european security all of those previous
discussions about european strategic
autonomy have proven to be far too early
the white house is increasingly facing
what it deems to be major security
threats on two fronts china and russia
two foes forging a deepening strategic
alliance according to nato the closer
beijing and moscow got the more the u.s
will be looking to its european partners
to forge an alliance of democracies
for europe the big deal is energy
europeans need russian gas and yet
paying for it meant they were funding an
economy that they were also trying to
punish with sanctions
russia has been europe's biggest
supplier of energy and for decades
member countries of the european union
could rely on cheap russian gas imports
to heat homes and to power their
industry
as part of the sanctions the eu imposed
on moscow for its aggression on ukraine
the bloc began weaning itself off of
russian oil coal and gas ending decades
of dependency on russian fossil fuels
the war in ukraine is testing unity as
spheres grow that russia which has
already been restricting gas supply will
completely turn off the taps eu member
countries took the decision
to reduce their consumption so as to
save to have enough for the winter but
some member countries feel that it's
unfair that everybody's been asked to
reduce by the same amount even though
not everybody uses the same amount of
russian gas
russia was once considered a strategic
partner it's now been designated the
most significant threat to peace and
stability in the euro area
that's led to finland and sweden taking
the historic decision to join nato
for their part nato allies have
committed to increasing their defence
spending and the alliance has bolstered
its presence in europe increasing the
number of troops
the economic fallout of the war is
making life harder everywhere
it's combined with the uneven recovery
from the corona pandemic to produce
inflation worse than has been seen in
decades even before russia's invasion
prices had already been climbing the
pandemic had scrambled supply chains
leading to shortages and then there was
an energy crunch energy producers scaled
back production when lockdowns depressed
demand but then the global economy
bounced back with a vengeance and energy
demand and energy prices did the same
together ukraine and russia produce
about a fourth of global wheat supplies
but the war made getting grain out of
the so-called fred basket of the world
difficult even though deals have since
been struck to change that it has
however put a strain on many countries
dependent on those imports and made food
around the world harder to afford
central banks around the world are
trying to cool inflation by raising
interest rates the idea is that by
making money more expensive to borrow
people will buy and spend less and that
will dial back demand and help prices
climb back down
theoretically anyway but that also means
slowing down and already slowing economy
even further
and maybe even tipping it into recession
there's also a limit to what central
banks can do they cannot grow wheat they
cannot produce energy and they cannot
stop the war and as further developments
in that war remain uncertain so too does
the outlook for the global economy
uncertainty
complexity
instability
division
six months on the ukraine war is
cascading through human lives everywhere
the unwelcome effects will likely make
things harder and more dangerous long
after the war ends
you